Continental Tire coaches corner as we
make way for the Duke head coach Mike
sous-chefs key if this college coaching
thing doesn't work out he can always go
into interviewing celebrities because
something he does do a show on Channel
84 Sirius XM ESPNU radio Thursdays at
6:00 Eastern weekly throughout college
basketball season some of the guests
this year have included Dale Earnhardt
jr. Brett Favre Gregg Popovich Grant
Hill Bobby Flay and yours truly kind of
desperate to get somebody weren't you
coach no we had a slow week and everyone
else canceled and I appreciate you
stepping in it's one of those it makes
the weeks we have celebrities on it
stand out yeah thank you for doing that
it was you know if it was like what you
would want a really good bench player to
do for your team thank you yeah you
stepped in and you filled a void and you
were good you're good now you plugged
your your university or school and all
that yeah it was kind of self promoting
but self you know if sold it still
that's space and time that we needed to
sell so I'm forever appreciative okay
and I told people this that we're taping
this interview yesterday there's a fire
alarm going on in the background while
you're doing the interview with me did
you ever find and was there a fire going
on where you were doing this interview
you know what your topic of discussion
was so hot and like that it turned the
fire alarm on it's never happened in the
show and so I didn't want yeah I just
wanted to continue the interview because
the only way it would stop is and it did
stop when you know we finished the
interview and we went on and so did you
know that you can do that I have had
that ability people have said I was in
Fuego before but I did not know I was
worried I figured you had handlers who
would just drag you out of the building
when the fire alarm went off so I well
they they brought into throne and the
carriers but I said wait a minute we
can't leave
you know we can't leave this this guy's
hot he's uh you know he's finally
hitting a shot let him continue to shoot
so there was some unbelievable day
yesterday thank you there was a lot of
fun and I appreciated the hours I
enjoyed it I enjoyed it who's the one
person that you you just say that's
that's the one I still want to get I
want to interview that person there
isn't like just one I'd like to
interview a few more people outside of
sport late leaders and business or
government or you know in in other
aspects of society you know and just
because it's a it's all about how you
you know one if you're a leader how you
lead your team and we talked a little
bit about that with you and but also how
you got there decisions you have to make
along the way to continue your journey
to you know to do what you're doing and
and I learned a lot of that when I
started speaking in the night early 90s
for the Washington speaker's bureau on
you go to different companies and you're
speaking you saying that grow these
people really do this Wow or boy that's
an interesting wait they phrase this a
certain thing how they're analyzing that
and so that's one of the things I've
loved about the show and I'd like to get
even more people like that and but you
know we've had you know like a week the
week before we had Gregg Popovich on and
that was a great great interview yeah
it's not so much an interview it's a
conversation yeah I don't like when I do
your show you know it's a good hopefully
it's a really good conversation but it's
a conversation more so than being asked
questions and being interviewed yeah and
that's the point I try to make is I want
you to I want you to talk to me instead
of just answer questions we had Dale
Earnhardt jr. and you know he started
talking about some pretty heavy stuff he
just talked about being in therapy as a
young child watching his mom's house
burned down and then his
mom has to give up custody of him and
his sister to his dad and you know next
thing you know you're like you're
letting people eavesdrop and that's what
I always want and I yeah and I like that
and I appreciated Dale jr. in fact
reached out to him after to say thank
you for allowing us in because you have
to open up to allow somebody in to give
the you know sort of that special access
and and that's what's fun when you're
able to kind of break down those walls
or you listen to somebody and they're
d'être cueing is the prime example coach
when we've had Patrick on I can't tell
you the number of times when people go I
didn't realize he had a sense of humor I
didn't know that he was like but you
know we saw him at Georgetown and
everybody thought that that's just who
Patrick Ewing is and he's not no he's a
great guy and he does have a great life
and an amazing sense of here no I
I understand that very well and you know
that's what I try to do and obviously
you guys are masters at it you do it
every day for three hours and I do it
for you know one hour you know a week 26
or 27 times a year but I've enjoyed I've
learned a lot and I'd done that so for
13 years the you know coaches I think
they still have this coaches would have
like call-in shows you know yeah and
when I first started at Duke we had one
and I'd go every Sunday night to some
studio and Jim from Fuquay and Sam from
apex we call and after doing this for a
while nothing against them but I I was
driving home one day I said look I'm
certainly no I don't want to talk to Jim
and Sam you know I want to be with my
family and so I stopped doing this show
and submitted my wife said we can we you
know you know we could make someone acid
it's not worth it it's not worth it I
don't want to do so this thing came up
and
and you know it's totally different so
we had you know you know Dan from
Connecticut yeah yesterday yeah so that
was a or from Zanesville Ohio yeah
that's where you're from I was born in
Zanesville Ohio Janesville okay yeah you
did some research there cuz I did I
stopped right there okay or somebody did
some research for you we're talking to
Coach K the cotton attire Coaches Corner
got a good handle on your team we're
getting it you know I don't think well
yes a better handle than we did before
we played nine games in 20 days and
which we just finished I I liked my
group a lot and in that day they have a
real will to win and they're not afraid
of moments they're not afraid of
pressure moments day they've responded
really well to end up game last four
minutes of games or overtime really well
and now do we have slippage I'm not
saying it's even slippage means we were
real good and then we slept are we
really good in a in everything no you
know but we want to be good and when we
get practice time if we stay healthy I
think we'll get better and but they're
really an amazing good group of kids
never had a good loss coach yeah you
know I mean well you know what I would
say this is it's up to you to make the
most of a win or loss you know like
because it's your next play so when you
do have a loss you know it's an
opportunity if you have the right
attitude and the beliefs and the
preparation of you know making whatever
changes needed to be made that would you
know yeah you take advantage of that and
sometimes it's a loss at the end of the
season that motivates you to make some
changes so that the next season you're
better and I always look at it as we're
on a continuum in our Pro
and it never ends you know it just never
ends but it's up to you as a leader to
take advantage of a win or a loss you
know what we're trying to do right now
is move on
you know after winning our first nine
games and being in some hellacious
situations you know in big-time games
and where these guys actually we met
this morning before they went to class
and one of the things I told them I said
you know you will want to play but as
the season moves along you have got to
want to prepare to play and that's what
a lot of teams a lot of people don't
they get tired of the preparation to
play to win and I said so we're in this
next segment of the season right now can
we continue to you know make that a good
habit of preparation and not just you
know the willingness or the excitement
to play who's Marvin Bagley remind you
boy he doesn't yeah he reminds me of a
great point you know he are you
surprised how good he is yeah you know I
am because you don't know it kid until
you coach them and and then not just in
practice but in games and you know I
knew obviously he's a great kid great
family really unbelievable talent but
what I didn't realize is just what an
amazing worker he was and he really
wants to be good and he wants to be
special and he's willing to pay the
price it's he has a where we caught you
know a motor he has a great motor he
wants to learn he he hangs on your words
you know he's an incredible listener and
ask questions and puts in the time as a
great teammate really has no demons at
all he's uh he's going to be
he's gonna be you know one of the
players I think of his era you know he's
gonna be a select one of those guys but
does it bother you that you only get him
for four more months actually you know I
wish we had a system in where he didn't
even have to make this stop you know
though I think he's learning a lot from
this spot this stop yeah but he you know
he's he could be a pro player now I'm
not saying he's going to be the great
pro player now but you know Marvin can
play in the NBA you know right now and
and he'd be could be you'd be good you
know now what he's learned here I think
has helped him and he'll be better
prepared but he can he play in the NBA
right now absolutely and there's there
are kids like that
that could come right out of high school
and be in the NBA and that's why it you
know I hope we can get rid of the one
and done things so that these kids have
the opportunities to make decisions that
is best for them and their families and
if going to college is that decision and
that's good but then it's their decision
it's not forced upon them and but I'm
glad I have the opportunity of being
being with them it's it makes me a
better coach it's very exciting to coach
them we did some research do you know
how many people in America are named
like sous chefs key what I think is
probably more leaving a six six are they
coaching in any other place or I I think
you're the most successful coach out of
the the other Mike Schuh chefs keys but
we're Pauly would you check on that
we're looking down okay yeah but we
believe you're the most successful coach
out of all the Mike sous-chefs keys in
America safe see recently done and
research first of all I'm wondering how
many chefs keys there are out there
there there aren't many of us a lot of
us change our names you know like my dad
because of a lot of discrimination that
he never went by suggest he went by the
name of cross k ro SS even in the
military in World War two he he was
William cross man you know a lot of the
stanislavski's in the world or Stanley's
yeah yeah and so did you think about
changing your name no never never ever
and but you know in when I was in grade
school I went to a Polish Catholic grade
school and if you wanted to you could
take Polish and my parents didn't want
me to and and or my brother and part of
it again was this discrimination they
didn't want me to have an accent because
at that time when you know my
grandparents migrated from Poland it was
there was a lot of a lot of stuff to
hold on and where if he had an accent or
yeah your you were head of all at the
end of your name you know
something wasn't gonna happen for you
and I didn't realize that till later
until I became an adult that those were
the reasons that my dad went by cross
and why we didn't really I do not I wish
I did
and however my parents you say use that
as a weapon
no because when they didn't want us to
know anything basic forward and so what
the hell are they talking about they're
talking about you and that's how I went
to West Point
I turned West Point down and my parents
kept talking in the kitchen Tim polished
and they would talk and polish and all
of a sudden they use a couple English
words like stupid
necessary I said what do you mean I said
you you should go to West Point you know
that's where presidents go that's for
you know for a Polish kid no man I'll go
yeah so I I went I went to West Point
it was never my decision that I trusted
my parents enough
and I didn't want to disappoint him and
it was the best decision I ever
I never made never made it's crazy you
know some of the things that just
happened to you along the way that are
fortuitous you know like like for if my
parents did not you know believe in me
and believe in education and you know
believe that they wanted something
better than what they had for their sons
you know I mean I there's no way I'd be
doing what I'm doing today if I didn't
go to West Point
no way it's just absolutely no way and
you know that's why sometimes you when
kids are making decisions at 17 and
parents say well it's Jimmy's decision
or or Mary's decision I said yeah well
give them some input yeah you know don't
nothing wrong with little guidance
they're not yeah guidance is a good
thing and theirs was a little bit more
ethnically force guidance Hey coach
thank you again as always have fun
yesterday glad you could join us and
good luck we'll talk to you during the
season thanks and if we ever need a you
know we don't get a celebrity you're on
my speed I'm Jon Scheyer I'm there for
all right Coach K Continental Tire
coaches Kohner from Sunday rain to snow
and everything in between Continental
tires engineer tire for what you do
extraordinary performance and
reliability putting confidence into your
driving for more info and location near
you visit Continental Tire calm cutting
up tire for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]